film sully came out it was a great movie
fantastic movie i love it oh my god so
i'm so happy because i have a companion
piece
to that movie uh because that's the
whole story was not told you know clint
eastwood did a fine job i did a fine job
who knows who did a better job it
doesn't matter but
you have a competing sully movie how to
competing a companion so when it when it
finally comes on netflix it will say
you know the sully sullenberger you
watch this sunlight you'll watch that
and then it will say if you liked that
movie conan yeah conan just conan i know
so
i'm sorry i know you hate that no if you
if you like that movie conan
you will love
sully sullenberger airport pilot
which i did
see
you do your version you and you shot
this yes and that's just right you play
sully sullenberger in your mind i play
sully sullenberger tom hanks plays him
in the other movie who's to say who's
better it's an age-old debate the point
is this you watch them together you get
the whole story because i watched sully
it's him landing on the hudson and then
what happened after what is yours
covered mine covers what he does before
it's called suddenly sullenberger
airport this is before he lands on the
hudson like a year or two before yeah
yeah yeah it's a pretty cool yeah yeah
all right let's take a look at zoe
sullenberger
i play sully yeah
uh on behalf of uh usair
line
uh we know you have a lot of choices to
make and uh we're glad you chose us have
fun in kansas city everybody
[Applause]
that's not a movie i didn't choose that
clip there's a there's a better clip
that i gave there's a better clip yeah
there's a better clip than that i hope
there's a better clip the story is a
love story that's what i was trying to
get what nobody knows about mrs
sullenberger old ruth sullenberger oh
and they have a they have a this is this
clip shows their real love for each
other yeah it's lovely okay here we go
sully why didn't you give me a seat why
do i have to stand here for the whole
flight i told you it's cheaper
to save it up for the thing
now listen
you know why you're standing up here i'm
just kidding you i love you that's why
hey you wanna you wanna
land this yeah
pretty well lands itself
[Applause]
okay
uh
oh that girl will be so happy yeah
i i got her i found her at your show
yeah i'm sure you did discovered her
program in new york yeah and i cast her
and she's gonna be so happy she'll be
very happy
she'll make tens of dollars off that
uh okay based on a true story a memoir
is available now season three of norm
mcdonald live can be found at
youtube.com slash norman i've missed you
fellas i'll tell you that
or amazon prime norm would you it's just
i never know what's going to happen and
you're truly one of the most delightful
odd people i've ever met i love you norm
mcdonald i love him we'll be right back